the anisee mayor Francois are stored
it's been speaking to bfm TV and this is
our translation of that headline um
saying although they don't specify how
many some children have left the
operating room their condition seems
stable an adult is still in the
operating room just to remind you one
adult and four children uh were stabbed
and it was thought that the adult and
two children were in a very serious
condition while two of the children were
in serious condition with their lives
not thought to be in danger so the
update uh just there if we can just roll
back up again saying that two of the
children I think was the headline there
just to clarify once again uh our
thoughts to have left the operating room